Caption: so I'm just going to introduce myself
Caption: because I want to get
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: they play the audience can I just leave
Caption: now
Caption: um I want to get you out of here on time
Caption: well as much on time as I can
Caption: um there's a pronunciation my name is
Caption: aish
Caption: um I am so Aisha Works in and around
Caption: technology projects she won some awards
Caption: a few years ago but the important thing
Caption: is she loves figuring out how diverse
Caption: teams work at their best
Caption: so now I'm going to switch the first
Caption: person
Caption: if you haven't already there's a QR code
Caption: up on here for you to scan it basically
Caption: gives you access to the slides and the
Caption: closed captions on your device uh emote
Caption: as well it'll be like Microsoft teams
Caption: and I'm going to want a lot of that
Caption: because I need validation and this is
Caption: nice for me
Caption: but it also means that at the end of the
Caption: session you'll have an opportunity to
Caption: give me feedback it's completely
Caption: anonymous
Caption: and it comes straight into my inbox at
Caption: the very end of the session and I would
Caption: really love to hear from you so for
Caption: people in person and online hopefully
Caption: you can see this QR code it'll be on the
Caption: next slide as well hi mum and dad
Caption: they're on the YouTube live
Caption: foreign
Caption: hello and welcome my name is aish
Caption: how lucky are we to live and work on
Caption: it's incredible that we get to be here
Caption: in face to face in a conference after
Caption: such a long time and all the wonderful
Caption: conversations that we've had today right
Caption: in the heart of Perth and burulu and I
Caption: just want to express my gratitude to all
Caption: the traditional custodians of this
Caption: beautiful land for continuing to share
Caption: their culture and their Traditions with
Caption: us
Caption: thank you all if your logo is up on here
Caption: as well
Caption: um without you and your support as
Caption: sponsors we would not be here today
Caption: thanks for giving emerging speakers like
Caption: me an opportunity to get the hang of
Caption: this thing
Caption: let's get into the show now
Caption: I know you all voted for the swear word
Caption: in the title but thanks anyway
Caption: while you get comfortable with
Caption: PowerPoint live let me tell you a little
Caption: bit about me that's myself and Donna
Caption: Boyd up here last year talking about
Caption: product ownership it was our first ever
Caption: conference talk and I'm clearly a
Caption: glutton for punishment so I'm back at it
Caption: I am an idealist
Caption: I never really outgrew that naive little
Caption: girl who wants to adopt old dogs in the
Caption: shelter save the whales and world hunger
Caption: joined the United Nations
Caption: but I did realize that the best way for
Caption: me to make change is to focus in on the
Caption: things that I'm good at
Caption: the things that I like doing the things
Caption: the world needs and things I can get
Caption: paid for
Caption: and that is focusing in on that
Caption: intersection between business technology
Caption: and social impact
Caption: it's because of that I'm incredibly
Caption: passionate about diversity and inclusion
Caption: I mean how can I not be but it's about
Caption: leveraging diversity and inclusion to
Caption: enable and support
Caption: sustainable High performing teams and
Caption: that's exactly what we're going to talk
Caption: about today
Caption: is human
Caption: to learn divine
Caption: hindsight's always 20 20. if only we had
Caption: that in 2020
Caption: it's really difficult to take a moment
Caption: to pause and reflect on difficult times
Caption: particularly when you're right in the
Caption: middle of it now I had a lot of really
Caption: great ideas on how to actually run this
Caption: session you know I had this Vision that
Caption: I was live facilitating and you were
Caption: like screaming your frustrations out at
Caption: me and some of the worst projects that
Caption: you've ever been a part of but I wasn't
Caption: sure that I'd be able to get you angry
Caption: and then calm again in 20 minutes so you
Caption: don't go outside picking fights with
Caption: people
Caption: but also you're here to listen and to
Caption: learn not to work
Caption: so I had that session with smaller
Caption: groups of people who already had a high
Caption: level of psychological safety
Caption: and these are the four things that we
Caption: came up with the four top challenges
Caption: that we're going to unpack today one by
Caption: one
Caption: it's not my job get your remote hands up
Caption: eye rolls groans if you've heard this
Caption: before
Caption: well if it's not your job whose job is
Caption: it then
Caption: if you're hearing this in your Retros or
Caption: in your projects towards the end of a
Caption: reporting cycle or whatever it might be
Caption: it basically means that there have been
Caption: assumptions that have gone wrong but
Caption: I've been proven to be wrong someone has
Caption: assumed that this isn't part of their
Caption: role and you have assumed that it is
Caption: cannot assume
Caption: that people understand what their role
Caption: is
Caption: you cannot assume that people's
Caption: interpretation of their role is the same
Caption: as yours this is especially true for
Caption: multivendor teams and teams where you
Caption: have a mix of operational project and
Caption: product people we each have a different
Caption: lens that we bring into what our role
Caption: actually means and what it means to work
Caption: and how they interact with each other
Caption: and it's incredibly important that we
Caption: actually bring ourselves together to get
Caption: that common understanding about common
Caption: Clarity on how we'll work together today
Caption: what you need to do is First Steps do we
Caption: all actually agree on what our problem
Caption: is
Caption: do we understand what we're trying to
Caption: solve why are we even here in the first
Caption: place
Caption: when you have a Clarity or in that then
Caption: you can do your visioning what's that
Caption: desired outcome where are we heading to
Caption: what do we want to be in three six
Caption: months years time what are we trying to
Caption: get to
Caption: from there you have to understand what
Caption: are the things that you actually need to
Caption: do forget your project methodology for a
Caption: moment but what do you actually need to
Caption: get done
Caption: what's your value chain
Caption: that's going to get you to where you
Caption: want to go
Caption: when you have that value chain
Caption: understood and broken down as much as
Caption: you possibly can to get your best
Caption: estimates from here you can have a look
Caption: around and think and talk about the kind
Caption: of project methodology you think is
Caption: better is going to suit your project the
Caption: best what roles are available to you and
Caption: then you can agree and assign those
Caption: roles and responsibilities
Caption: what's within your remit today
Caption: now you might be talking to me and like
Caption: might be thinking in your head we've
Caption: done this and there's still things that
Caption: come up that we don't know who it
Caption: belongs to or maybe you're trying you're
Caption: thinking about well the product that
Caption: we're working on doesn't actually have a
Caption: very you know clearly defined outcome
Caption: well it's true we don't have a crystal
Caption: ball and we don't know always what's
Caption: going to come up and potentially derail
Caption: us on our journey to our end Vision or
Caption: our end goal
Caption: this is where you come together as a
Caption: team and you actually talk about the
Caption: roles that are available to you and your
Caption: team
Caption: what are your experiences in previous
Caption: projects in previous organizations how
Caption: have you worked with a project sponsored
Caption: previously what do you expect your
Caption: tester to do
Caption: are there some roles or some
Caption: responsibilities I should say that your
Caption: change manager would traditionally be
Caption: responsible for but in this particular
Caption: project it makes more sense for your ba
Caption: to do that
Caption: what's within your remit today what's
Caption: the social contract that you're forming
Caption: someone clearly did not think it was
Caption: their role to clear the path before
Caption: painting and I don't think it led to a
Caption: remarkable outcome
Caption: in a game of he said she said you're
Caption: going to want to keep your receipts I
Caption: don't care how or just make sure that
Caption: you do
Caption: number two
Caption: we don't do things that way have you
Caption: heard this before you've come in new to
Caption: the team and you've tried to like
Caption: introduce a new way of working sorry
Caption: mate you must be a bit new here we don't
Caption: really do things that way things have
Caption: been working fine until you came along
Caption: there's not enough angry emojis in there
Caption: but I love it
Caption: it can be pretty tricky to balance
Caption: Chaos and Order particularly when you're
Caption: trying to manage the different people's
Caption: expectations and their different Comfort
Caption: levels along with the type of project
Caption: methodology that's going to suit the
Caption: organization that you're delivering to
Caption: where customers are comfortable with
Caption: what your team's personalities are and
Caption: so on and so forth
Caption: often you'll find people gravitating
Caption: towards process and
Caption: um procedures in more like governance
Caption: heavy and regulation in heavy
Caption: environments or when people are
Caption: particularly uncomfortable with chaos
Caption: as consultants we're often asked to
Caption: bring a best practice approach to
Caption: executing work and it's fantastic for us
Caption: to be able to lean on our experiences
Caption: on what's worked really well before
Caption: other similar companies or the similar
Caption: size projects
Caption: but the thing about software development
Caption: is the sheer number of variables means
Caption: that well there's no real silver bullet
Caption: to delivering an outcome
Caption: there's so many things that you need to
Caption: consider when deciding on what's the
Caption: best approaching technique that you can
Caption: take
Caption: what are the Project funding cycles and
Caption: how does your team report to them
Caption: what kind of legal and Regulatory bodies
Caption: do you sit under there's so much that
Caption: you have to consider here
Caption: there's another talk about best fit and
Caption: best practice that I think happened
Caption: earlier today I would love to catch that
Caption: online and I highly highly recommend
Caption: that you do too if you weren't able to
Caption: get to it because there are so many
Caption: different ways to organize yourselves
Caption: and execute work and someone might
Caption: organize themselves in a different way
Caption: to you
Caption: I am talking about both the
Caption: opportunities when you're trying to
Caption: introduce a new step in the process or
Caption: when you're actually trying to take
Caption: something out
Caption: I can't count the number of times that
Caption: someone's come to me with an idea to
Caption: potentially or to my team let's organize
Caption: the backlog a little bit differently
Caption: or let's add a little bit more structure
Caption: to Sprint planning and it's always been
Caption: met with resistance to change and that's
Caption: the key thing about this particular
Caption: topic as humans we aren't naturally
Caption: resistant to change there's a lot of
Caption: fear there's a lot of not being able to
Caption: learn something from scratch or not
Caption: performing well enough while you are
Caption: learning
Caption: but in this particular instance as well
Caption: there could be some level of insecurity
Caption: about you know why isn't the way that
Caption: we've been working good enough
Caption: what's wrong with it we've gotten here
Caption: so um all this way so far
Caption: change only happens when the pain of
Caption: staying the same is greater than the
Caption: pain of change
Caption: and the best thing to do in this
Caption: scenario is to do something with and
Caption: through someone rather than to them
Caption: bring your folks together and actually
Caption: have that Frank discussion about
Caption: what are the gaps that you're seeing
Caption: what are the blockers and the
Caption: bottlenecks that you want to address
Caption: chances are others are potentially
Caption: feeling it too but maybe they're too
Caption: nervous to speak up or maybe they're too
Caption: focused on the doing to be able to pause
Caption: and reflect on how they're doing
Caption: when you have people collaborating
Caption: together on the solution it actually
Caption: you're actually empowering people to
Caption: have ownership of the changes that
Caption: you're trying to get them to adapt to
Caption: ask the question though is this actually
Caption: going to help or hinder us this extra
Caption: step that we're going to put in before
Caption: we make a decision is that going to lead
Caption: to better decisions are there other ways
Caption: that we can get the same outcome even if
Caption: it's not from a Playbook or a scrum
Caption: guide
Caption: the main thing to remember though is to
Caption: experiment
Caption: give people a refund policy give them a
Caption: bit of a way out basically
Caption: um
Caption: test the waters give something a red hot
Caption: go before coming together as a team to
Caption: evaluate is this actually working for us
Caption: maybe it's uncovered something else that
Caption: we'd rather focus on
Caption: building a culture of experimentation
Caption: into your team early on makes it so much
Caption: easier for you to add incremental change
Caption: into your into the way that your team
Caption: Works more often because people are
Caption: going to be comfortable and familiar
Caption: that change is only going to stick when
Caption: it's actually working for you but
Caption: experimentation also also allows you and
Caption: your team to scale as your product
Caption: matures
Caption: oh
Caption: we don't get anything done we didn't
Caption: finish our Sprints because you know they
Caption: just kept changing their minds we can't
Caption: seem to get anything right here
Caption: yeah
Caption: if you're hearing this let's talk about
Caption: it
Caption: scope creep changing requirements
Caption: acrobatic backflipping clients it's a
Caption: circus out there
Caption: the agile Manifesto was essentially born
Caption: out of many of the challenges that we've
Caption: discussed today
Caption: but this is my favorite way of
Caption: explaining why socializing your product
Caption: early and often is the best way to avoid
Caption: surprises
Caption: you've probably experienced this where
Caption: your ba or your product owner or your
Caption: customer themselves have spoken to you
Caption: about this is what we want build it
Caption: we've gone and done the thing showed it
Caption: to them
Caption: nah
Caption: the thing about changing requirements is
Caption: though or changing your mind like
Caption: everything in moderation like I said
Caption: before we don't have a crystal ball and
Caption: we don't expect everyone's going to get
Caption: everything right the first time
Caption: this is why feedback loops are so
Caption: important early and often to make sure
Caption: that you'll be able to catch this
Caption: sooner rather than later and be able to
Caption: have that conversation and go on the
Caption: journey with your client
Caption: we want to create Sustainable Solutions
Caption: and happy customers and regular feedback
Caption: is the best way to do that
Caption: there's no sound but that's the caption
Caption: at the end of the day
Caption: you can spend all the time in the world
Caption: understanding your customer spending
Caption: time with them showcasing your product
Caption: regularly and early
Caption: you can understand their preferences and
Caption: their style and still they might keep
Caption: changing their minds there could be a
Caption: few underlying reasons for this that
Caption: they might not be upfront about with you
Caption: maybe there's some funding issues that
Caption: they're not at Liberty to discuss with
Caption: you
Caption: or maybe they're just not the right
Caption: people to actually make a decision at
Caption: the end of it
Caption: there's still a few things if you feel
Caption: like you have the ability to influence
Caption: that you can still do here
Caption: help them build empathy for what it
Caption: costs you to deal with their change of
Caption: mind
Caption: set your boundaries firmly but gently
Caption: but explain why
Caption: bring them on the journey with you and
Caption: don't assume
Caption: that they know what it costs you
Caption: there's uh one of my favorite things to
Caption: do is the power of contrast
Caption: I love presenting one good option that I
Caption: want them to choose and then another
Caption: option that's technically feasible but
Caption: otherwise potentially not quite suitable
Caption: it's much easier to be able to see and
Caption: poke holes in something when you can
Caption: actually see it
Caption: presenting multiple options is also a
Caption: fantastic way to
Caption: demonstrate the evolution of a product
Caption: vision and the ideas that all of you
Caption: have had whether it be from a user's
Caption: point of view or from a technical
Caption: feasibility point of view
Caption: I've definitely been in scenarios when
Caption: we've been on a bit of a journey on what
Caption: that product should be doing and we've
Caption: got customers who tend to sort of revert
Caption: to thinking that they had maybe three
Caption: months ago six months ago why can't we
Caption: do it that way again I can't remember
Caption: everyone's got a lot going on there's
Caption: probably lots of projects that they're
Caption: all spread across out on but presenting
Caption: multiple options and being able to see
Caption: that contrast can vividly show and
Caption: demonstrate the difference between where
Caption: we are now where we started from and
Caption: clearly explaining why what is the
Caption: evolution of our thought process here
Caption: don't forget to reinforce any further
Caption: benefits of the current state of what
Caption: you've built and let them know about
Caption: ongoing support and feedback
Caption: opportunities as well
Caption: anything you can do to ease a little bit
Caption: of a fear of commitment
Caption: easier said than done for most
Caption: but if you don't respect your own time
Caption: and your own sanity other people won't
Caption: either
Caption: finally
Caption: it's retro time
Caption: you're talking about what you want to
Caption: keep doing stop doing start doing
Caption: and your team are all voting on how well
Caption: this Sprint went
Caption: you're getting fours and fives out of
Caption: five
Caption: but maybe you didn't actually finish
Caption: your stories
Caption: maybe some blockers weren't escalated
Caption: and dependencies on other teams were
Caption: left really really late
Caption: now I am specifically talking about
Caption: those Sprints where
Caption: things weren't in Tip-Top shape but your
Caption: team are quite close-knit
Caption: and feeling a bit self-congratulatory or
Caption: maybe they're ignoring the elephants in
Caption: the room or maybe they're actually
Caption: voting more on how each of you as
Caption: individuals dealt with the challenges
Caption: that your team faced rather than how the
Caption: Sprint actually went
Caption: retrospectives are an opportunity to
Caption: come together as a team and evaluate how
Caption: people process and tools are coming
Caption: together
Caption: to help you and your team deliver it's
Caption: not about airing daily laundry and we're
Caption: not asking for people to come out and
Caption: point fingers and start fights or
Caption: anything like that
Caption: it is about balance and
Caption: if you have a team that seems to be
Caption: unwilling to speak about the real issues
Caption: that are impacting delivery it could be
Caption: a sign that they're lacking
Caption: psychological safety
Caption: you don't need hardly Business Review to
Caption: tell you that psychological safety is
Caption: the Cornerstone of high performing and
Caption: multi-disciplinary teams teams I'm sure
Caption: each of us working day in Day Out
Caption: but it's also means that cognitive
Caption: diversity diversity of thought is better
Caption: leveraged when people are comfortable
Caption: with each other and familiar with
Caption: alternative points of view
Caption: building psychological safety in your
Caption: team is hard work it takes time and
Caption: energy but it is well worth it
Caption: you can start by encouraging your team
Caption: to understand themselves assess
Caption: themselves think about how they like to
Caption: think work and behave
Caption: doing this helps you uncover any
Caption: cognitive biases that you might have
Caption: that could potentially be contributing
Caption: to the problem or the culture that you
Caption: might have that you're trying to tackle
Caption: understanding how you like to respond to
Caption: change or how you respond to conflict
Caption: can almost give you a moment to
Caption: basically decide how you're going to
Caption: respond to some stimulus
Caption: but simple things like taking an
Caption: interest in people's lives and actively
Caption: soliciting questions from them giving
Caption: them multiple channels to give feedback
Caption: and to communicate depending on their
Caption: personality types these are things that
Caption: you can do no matter your position on
Caption: the team formal leadership or not
Caption: and if you do have a Culture of Fear
Caption: that's stopping people from sharing
Caption: ideas the moments that somebody actually
Caption: does
Caption: you need to be ready with the positive
Caption: response
Caption: if you are in a formal leadership team
Caption: you have it is critical though that you
Caption: are clear and precise with your
Caption: expectations because this is how you
Caption: build trust and build reliability within
Caption: your team
Caption: if you make mistakes own up to them if
Caption: there are changes explain them
Caption: be more human be divine be vulnerable
Caption: cannot underestimate the influence that
Caption: you have on Team Dynamics no matter your
Caption: position on the team culture is top down
Caption: but
Caption: the individual behaviors basically
Caption: explain to ourselves and to each other
Caption: what what we're willing to accept from
Caption: our colleagues and from ourselves
Caption: and people are always responsible
Caption: responsive to purposeful and courageous
Caption: vulnerability
Caption: at the end of the day retrospectives are
Caption: about getting a team that's so focused
Caption: on the next big thing the next Sprint to
Caption: actually pause and reflect on what's
Caption: just been
Caption: they're a great way to introduce
Caption: incremental change but sometimes complex
Caption: problems can come up as well
Caption: complex problems are often the sign of a
Caption: team that has uh that's letting
Caption: something Fester because they don't feel
Caption: comfortable talking about it until it
Caption: eventually it explodes
Caption: every single framework to organize
Caption: people works capitalism communism the
Caption: free market a donor economy that is
Caption: until
Caption: people get involved
Caption: the things that make us different
Caption: make things so complicated
Caption: but the things that make us different
Caption: can make us even stronger if it's
Caption: harnessed appropriately
Caption: each of us are a product of our
Caption: experiences we've all experienced life
Caption: and work so differently and we bring
Caption: that into every single interaction that
Caption: we ever have
Caption: the way we respond to change the way we
Caption: set boundaries or don't the way we
Caption: respond to conflict
Caption: each of these can be a challenge turned
Caption: into an opportunity
Caption: if we just take a little bit of time out
Caption: of our days to pause and reflect on
Caption: what's just been
Caption: who we are now and where we want to go
Caption: and if we do this together as a team we
Caption: can make sure that our teams are humming
Caption: thanks DDD sponsors committee all of you
Caption: for coming along to my talk I really
Caption: appreciate it big shout out to Journey
Caption: once agile and product Community as well
Caption: for being my guinea pigs and my
Caption: brainstos brains trust please connect
Caption: with me let's have a chat if you agree
Caption: or disagree about anything I would love
Caption: to hear from you and the feedback on
Caption: your devices as well that's all folks
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: foreign
Caption: I mean I don't think we have time for
Caption: questions but I'll take them I don't
Caption: mind I got nowhere to be
Caption: I'm happy to
Caption: that's scary
Caption: it's gonna shoot you
Caption: hello
Caption: um and you talked about a lot about
Caption: setting boundaries and I think a lot of
Caption: us have experience with dealing with
Caption: quite difficult stakeholders do you have
Caption: any I guess General tips on how people
Caption: can approach conversations I guess
Caption: around setting boundaries
Caption: rhino
Caption: look when you're dealing with difficult
Caption: stakeholders Sometimes the best thing to
Caption: do is to Shield yourself and your team
Caption: as much as possible from them but
Caption: sometimes you know we're in a position
Caption: where we are the shield and that's going
Caption: to be tricky and there's a lot of things
Caption: that you'll have to balance your own
Caption: mental health your own capacity and
Caption: capability to deal with conflict in that
Caption: scenario we are all human and you cannot
Caption: be expected to deal in with hostile
Caption: um
Caption: circumstances day in Day Out there's a
Caption: lot of things that you can do to
Caption: mentally prepare yourself for a
Caption: difficult conversation doing whatever
Caption: works for you for mindfulness for taking
Caption: a walk clearing your mind preparing what
Caption: you're going to say coming in with notes
Caption: even bringing someone as a support
Caption: person in with you
Caption: those are the kind of things that I
Caption: would do before having knowing that I'm
Caption: about to have a difficult conversation
Caption: with someone and also don't forget to
Caption: expect that no matter what happens well
Caption: the word's not going to crash you're not
Caption: going to die like the worst thing that's
Caption: going to happen is you know maybe you
Caption: just don't like each other after a while
Caption: that's okay you're going to be fine
Caption: you're going to survive whatever a 30
Caption: minute conversation you've got in your
Caption: calendar you still have the rest of the
Caption: day to look forward to
Caption: foreign
Caption: I think you make a really good point
Caption: about having someone who can advocate
Caption: for you and and having that person
Caption: alongside you early lived experiences
Caption: this issue
Caption: um and knowing that you're uh you're
Caption: allowed to take a breath I was at a
Caption: pitch Night at the Museum I don't know
Caption: if anyone else was there The Innovation
Caption: night too and uh hosts talked about his
Caption: stutter and he said you might see me do
Caption: this and I might behaving this way and
Caption: that's because of this and he opened the
Caption: conversation for anyone else to share
Caption: what's going on for them so advocating
Caption: for each other and actually knowing that
Caption: we're all human and we all make mistakes
Caption: and we can all actually
Caption: um just collaborate beautiful thank you
Caption: thank you so much any other questions
Caption: yep I know half the people in this room
Caption: thanks
Caption: [Applause]